neue klimaziele für deutschland die
bundesregierung will viel schneller als
geplant den ausstoß von treibhausgasen
verringern
über die details gibt es noch streit
aufhol programm für schülerinnen und
schüler zwei milliarden euro sollen für
sie die folgen der pandemie besser
abfedern und ehre für den umstrittenen
nationalhelden frankreichs
staatspräsident bricht ein tabu und
würdigt den zweihundertsten todestag von
napoleon bonaparte
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers amt in allen zu der
welt an diesem mittwoch sport nachher in
der sendung mit kristin otto ich habe
fußball und tennis der balkon amt
deutschland soll schon bis 2045
klimaneutral werden also nur noch so
viele treibhausgase ausstoßen wie auch
wieder gebunden werden können
das ist fünf jahre eher als bisher
geplant und das hat erhebliche folgen
für die wirtschaft und für uns alle
die bundesregierung will damit jetzt
schnell umsteuern angestoßen hatte das
ganze ein urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts das bemängelt
die aktuelle regelung verschiebe zu
viele lasten auf künftige generationen
schon bei den zwischenschritten wird
deutlich mehr tempo gemacht so sollen
nun bis 2030 der treibhausgas ausstoß im
vergleich zu 1990 um 65 prozent sinken
geplant waren bisher nur 55 prozent
genaue details wie das geschehen soll
fehlen aber noch aus berlin andreas
ruppert
ungewöhnlich war der auftritt allemal
der bundesfinanzminister und die
bundesumweltministerin präsentieren den
neuentwurf des klimaschutzgesetzes zeigt
welche priorität die spd plötzlich der
umwelt und klimapolitik einräumt
besonders in wahlkampfzeiten das anders
als früher geplant wird diesmal nicht
die größte last in die zukunft verlegt
sondern jedes der dekade jede generation
übernimmt hier verantwortung dass es ein
plan der machbar ist der zielführend ist
und der planungssicherheit schafft diese
planungssicherheit schraubt die
klimaziele gleich ordentlich nach oben
und die treibhausgase hoffentlich nach
unten für das jahr 2040 wurde das
zwischenziel 88 prozent weniger co2 in
den gesetzentwurf geschrieben ab 20.45
soll deutschland dann klimaneutral sein
wir sehen einen korridor für eine
einigung auf ambitionierte und
vernünftige ziele und gleichzeitig auf
eine lösung die das generationenproblem
im blick hat
schön und gut finden die grünen
allerdings bleibe die frage wie die
bundesregierung diese ziele erreichen
will
durch ein ziel spart man keine einzige
tonne co2 ein
maßnahmen wie ein vorziehen des kohle
ausstiegs und den ausbau der
erneuerbaren
das wäre jetzt was die bundesregierung
an packen müsste die afg sieht durch das
neue klimaschutzgesetz vor allem die
deutsche wirtschaft in gefahr dass was
passieren wird wir werden millionen
arbeitsplätze verlieren wir werden
wohlstand verlieren und wir wären unsere
werden unsere position als führende
industrienationen verlieren das wird
messbar seien deutschland und der
klimaschutz im wahljahr 20 21 das thema
ganz oben auf der politischen agenda der
partei über die folgen für uns alle
reden wir gleich ausführlich erstmal
kurz der politische teil des ganzen mit
schale banerjee in berlin herrscht
akuter das bundesverfassungsgericht hat
da einiges angestoßen das thema ist ein
wichtiges ein enorm wichtiges im
wahlkampf wie viel wahlkampf steckt denn
jetzt in diesem vorhaben der regierung
es ist schon auffällig welche eile hier
jetzt gerade an den tag gelegt wird denn
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat dem
gesetzgeber eigentlich zeit gegeben bis
ende 2022 für nachbesserungen jetzt soll
das ganze innerhalb von einer woche
gewuppt werden
dazu sagt selbst der chef des
kanzleramtes das ist ein
rekordverdächtiges tempo
man bekommt hier den eindruck dass union
und spd möglichst schnell das kernthema
der grünen abräumen wollen bevor es in
die heiße wahlkampfphase geht und so dem
stärksten konkurrenten den wind aus den
segeln nehmen wollen die große frage ist
jetzt kommt da wirklich der große wurf
folgt der jetzt nach dieser ankündigung
wirtschaftsminister altmaier hat schon
darauf hingewiesen dass es schwierige
diskussionen werden im detail und bis
nächste woche mittwoch soll das ganze
jahr ins kabinett das ist nur eine woche
das ist nicht viel zeit um fragen zu
klären über die man sich in den letzten
zwei jahren nicht einigen konnte also
beide müssen jetzt nachweisen dass das
mehr ist als ein reines wahlkampfmanöver
dankeschön chuck unterlag
bringen wir unseren umweltexperten
volker angriffs dazu aus der zdf umwelt
redaktion oder im volk jetzt soll haben
wir gerade gehört alles ganz ganz
schnell gehen nach dem willen der
regierung fünf jahre früher klimaneutral
als bisher geplant welche dimension hat
dieses ziel damit du das mal erfassen
können das ist extrem sportlich wir
müssen uns ein bisschen zurück erinnern
wir haben jetzt gerade einmal 40 prozent
eingespart seit 1990
warum es das geschehen da gibt es zwei
gründe einmal der zusammenbruch der ddr
das war ein klimaschutz turbo seinerzeit
aber gar nichts für gekonnt das
passierte einfach und im letzten jahr
haben wir gesehen durch die korona
maßnahmen bis sie wirtschaft
runtergegangen
das hat auch noch mal etwas gebracht
dieser effekt ist natürlich auch vorbei
die wirtschaft geht wieder hoch und wir
werden schon mal mehr co2 haben also es
wird ganz ganz anstrengt und sehr sehr
sportlich werden für alle
wie das konkret zu bewerkstelligen ist
dazu haben wir jetzt im moment aus der
politik noch nicht allzu viel gehört
welche schritte wären denn nötig im
prinzip sind die schritte immer
dieselben im mittelpunkt steht der
ausbau der erneuerbaren energie also
windkraft- photovoltaik- oder auch gas
aus biomasse das sind die elemente
das ist zum stocken gekommen weil keine
regierung das einfach konsequent
durchgesetzt hat also stromtrassen bau
ist zum beispiel auch sonst ich vor da
gibt's bürgerinitiativen dagegen wird
protestiert es kommt nicht voran
windkraft manche sagen wir haben schon
genug verspargelung der landschaft wohin
denn mit diesen ganzen windrädern und es
wird nicht reichen der strombedarf
steigt immer mehr wir haben
elektromobilität funktioniert ja nur
sinnvoll mit grünem strom also aus
erneuerbaren energien
die industrie braucht dringend
wasserstoff als neuer energieträger
aber auch wer muss mit grünem strom aus
windkraft zum beispiel hergestellt
werden es reicht hinten und vorne nicht
neue konzepte müssen her
und eines dieser konzepte könnte sein
neue partnerschaften zu entwickeln zum
beispiel mit ländern im norden afrikas
um dort eben diesen grünen wasserstoff
herzustellen und den dann zu uns zu
bringen also viel zu tun wir lernen auch
das ist ein sehr ehrgeiziges ziel
was kommt denn da jetzt ganz konkret auf
uns alle zu na ja das wird eine
schwierige übergangsphase geben das
wären jobs wegfallen in den klassischen
industrie dem auf fossilen
energieträgern basieren auch in der
autoindustrie natürlich
und es wird später dann neue jobs geben
in dieser neuen wie sagen wir
nachhaltigen welt der co2 preis den
haben ja schon der wird wahrscheinlich
schneller steigen als bisher da wird's
für uns alle teurer beim tanken heizgas
aber es gibt eine ausgleichsmöglichkeit
und das muss die politik hinkriegen
soziale gerechtigkeit heißt auch zum
beispiel den strompreis runterzubringen
eeg-umlage weg dann wird die erneuerbare
energie günstiger das sind zum punkte
aber noch lange kann das noch viel mehr
zu tun sagt folge dass aus der zeit der
welt redaktion dankeschön volker und
damit heute abend zu unserem nächsten
thema kinder und jugendliche leiden
besonders unter der pandemie mit ihrem
kontakt beschränkungen
viele haben seit monaten keine schule
mehr von innen gesehen
das bundeskabinett hat heute 1 2
milliarden euro teures sogenanntes
corona aufhol paket beschlossen um die
folgen zumindest etwas zu lindern
es geht in deutschland um fast 11
millionen schülerinnen und schüler davon
haben 20 bis 25 große lern rückstände
aufzuholen sagt die bundesregierung und
nimmt kinder und jugendliche mit
migrationshintergrund noch mal besonders
in den blick bei den unter 15-jährigen
sind das fast 40 prozent
verena garrett berichtet die schule ist
zu hause fehlt ruhe
die diakonie stellt france lance und
ihrem sohn tyler einen raum zur
verfügung
tyler ist der jüngste von drei brüdern
seiner mutter ist alleinerziehend ohne
organisation läuft nichts ich mache
morgens wurde klasse homeschooling mit
dem jüngsten danach ist zurzeit
wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung chemie und
biologie der achten klasse dran
der große der branche moment nicht zu
helfen aber es ist doch im moment
schwierig ein alltag ohne struktur keine
sozialkontakte besonders hart trifft es
sozial schwache familien eine
anlaufstelle für sie das kinderhaus mal
statt jungen betroffenen der krise fehlt
es schon lange an angeboten sagen sie
erleben einfach kinder die sich deutlich
zurück entwickelt haben die psychische
ticks entwickelt haben
die zwangsstörungen entwickelt haben die
überhaupt keinen
geregelten tagesablauf haben das auch
wohl paket soll gegen steuern eine
milliarde euro für schüler mit großem
lärm rückständen das beinhaltet
nachhilfekurse bildungs und
freizeitangebote außerhalb der schule
und förderung der kernfächer deutsch und
mathematik sowie fremdsprachen eine
weitere milliarde euro soll psychische
folgen der krise abfedern mehr
schulsozialarbeit sprachförderung in
kitas und eine einmalzahlung von 100
euro für kinder aus familien mit
geringem einkommen
wir müssen davon ausgehen dass rund 20
bis 25 prozent der schülerinnen und
schüler deutliche lern rückstände wegen
der pandemie bedingten schulschließung
haben und deswegen sind wir überzeugt
dass diese schülerinnen und schüler
zusätzliche unterstützung brauchen nicht
genug durchdacht sagt der
bundesschülerkonferenz
ich glaube auch dass es nicht nur
einfach mit nachhilfe getan ist man muss
jetzt schauen wie man eben in
verschiedene wege gehen kann der eine
hat eben vielleicht im nachhilfe ein
problem der andere das kann man auch
sehen hat vielleicht ein problem darin
wie sich überhaupt selbst zu
strukturieren gerade bei den jüngeren
fehlt jetzt eben ein ganzes jahr bei
tiger ist nach einem jahr pandemie der
frust oft groß und die langeweile von
source lenz versuch das aufzufangen so
gut es geht und auch bei der
ganztagsbetreuung für grundschulkinder
soll es vorangehen auch das hat die
regierung heute auf den weg gebracht
aber august 2026 sollen erst einmal
kinder der ersten klasse einen
rechtsanspruch auf ganztagesbetreuung
haben in den jahren darauf dann jeweils
eine schulklasse mehr und zwar für
jeweils acht stunden an allen fünf
werktag mit einem spitzen duo will die
afg in den bundestagswahlkampf ziehen
jetzt hat fraktions chefin alice weidl
bekannt gegeben sie wolle zusammen mit
parteichef timo gruppe antreten weil
erklärte sich erst kurz vor ende der
bewerbungsfrist
als zweites duo kandidieren die
bundestagsabgeordnete johanna und der
pensionierte generalleutnant joachim
wundrak entschieden wird per afd
mitgliederbefragung
bei den corona zahlen in deutschland
weiter ein positiver trend das
robert-koch-institut registriert 18.000
34 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden das
sind 4197 weniger als am mittwoch vor
einer woche
285 menschen starben im zusammenhang mit
die bundesweite sieben tage incident
sinkt auf 132,8 dramatisch bleibt die
situation in indien wo zurzeit tausende
kranke nur deshalb sterben weil
medizinischer sauerstoff fehlt aus
deutschland ist weitere hilfe unterwegs
der erste teil einer mobilen sauerstoff
anlage der bundeswehr teil 2 folgt
morgen spätestens ab dem wochenende soll
die anlage dann pro tag genug sauerstoff
für 28 intensivpatienten unter vollbart
nun liefern wie wichtig jede hilfe für
die menschen in indien im moment ist
zeigen wir ihnen gleich erst wichtige
fakten zu einem riesen land der
gegensätze von pablo sie la la he mit
fast 1,4 milliarden einwohnern ist
indien die größte demokratie der welt
aber auch ein land extreme gegensätze
indien hat die drittmeisten milliardäre
weltweit gleichzeitig leben fast 100
millionen menschen ohne strom
etwa ein viertel hat keinerlei zugang zu
toiletten und fast 15 prozent der
menschen sind unterernährt
wirtschaftlich hat indien in kürzester
zeit den sprung vom entwicklungs zum
schwellenland geschafft und ist dabei
zur ökonomischen großmacht aufzusteigen
auch militärisch gibt sich die atommacht
selbstbewusst doch gesellschaftlich
prägt auch heute noch in vielen teilen
des landes das jahrhundertealte
hierarchische kastensystem das leben und
nicht immer profitieren die menschen vom
aufschwung indien gilt als apotheke der
welt doch die hier produzierten
medikamente und impfstoffe werden zum
großteil exportiert die folgen zeigen
sich in der korona krise besonders
dramatisch über 400.000 neue infektionen
an einem tag gemessen an der
einwohnerzahl mag das nicht viel
erscheinen doch experten gehen von einer
hohen dunkelziffer aus
und dann noch diese zahl fast 4000 tote
an nur einem tag meldet das indische
gesundheitsministerium so viele wie noch
nie
und dass sie nur die offiziellen zahlen
die tatsächlichen dürften um ein
vielfaches höher liegen
ein land zwischen verzweiflung und
versagen normen odenthal berichtet sie
kämpfen um jedes leben in indiens
krankenhäusern aber sie können ihr nur
für die kämpfen die überhaupt noch einen
platz finden
wir sind jetzt rein gekommen weil der
patient vorher gestorben ist deshalb
wurde das bett für meine mutter frei
jetzt bekommt sie sauerstoff
wir sind hier in der abstellkammer dabei
sollte sie auf die intensivstation die
sauerstoffflasche haben wir selbst
mitgebracht wir haben sie auf dem
schwarzmarkt gekauft
desaströs die zustände überall die wucht
der welle ist schlicht zu groß für das
gesundheitssystem indiens regierung
spielt das drama herunter wir noch nicht
mal den offensichtlichen
sauerstoffmangel eingestehen
zugleich wird sichtbar welche fatalen
fehler begangen wurden der
premierminister verkündete schon im märz
wir hätten den kampf gewonnen
da hat sich arroganz eingeschlichen
leichten und er versprach sogar in heben
würde ich jetzt die welt retten mit
seiner impfstoffproduktion tatsächlich
ist jetzt nicht mal für die eigene
bevölkerung genug impfstoff da die
produktion hakt weil rohstoffe fehlen
rufe nach einem landesweiten lockdown
werden lauter durch die regierung
fürchtet die wirtschaftlichen folgen so
werden die schrecklichen zahlen jeden
tag schrecklicher und das ist wohl noch
nicht mal das wahre bild
ich schätze dass 50 prozent der toten
gar nicht offiziell gezählt werden die
regierung zählt nur die aus den
krankenhäusern nicht die die zu hause
sterben und von freiwilligen heer
gebracht werden die bilder der
überlasteten krematorien stehen für das
ganze grauen sie gehen von indien in die
welt die eine warnung heute abend im
auslandsjournal zeige welchen mehr zur
lage in indien um 22 uhr 15 und nicht
nur dort weltweit brauchen menschen
hilfe im kampf gegen das virus das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe hat
dafür ein spendenkonto eingerichtet
stichwort zdf
ohne hilfe weltweit hier ist die iban
nummer dafür de 65 104 106 100 104 106
100 weitere informationen finden sie
auch im internet spenden zdf de und im
zdf text ab seite 800 90 unser nächstes
thema frankreich erinnert heute an einer
ebenso legendäre wie umstrittene
persönlichkeit napoleon bonaparte der
vor genau 200 jahren starb
geboren in korsika steigt er nach der
revolution 1789 in der armee rasant auf
1804 gründer sich selbst zum kaiser
überzieht europa mitkriegen schafft aber
auch reformen und ein modernes
zivilrecht sein niedergang kommt in
russland und in waterloo er stirbt in
der verbannung eine arbeit jetzt über
einen durchaus heiklen jahrestag eine
gedenkfeier für napoleon und sein
umstrittenes erbe das war lange ein tabu
emanuel makro jedoch nutzt den jahrestag
für einen auftritt nutzer brühl wir
wollen hier keine jubelfeier
veranstalten sowie die pariser damals
bei der rückkehr seiner sterblichen
überreste sondern eine aufgeklärte
zeremonie unserer geschichte ins auge
blicken
geschichte schrieb napoleon bonaparte
schon zu lebzeiten verstand es sich als
legende zu inszenieren
ein machtmensch der bis heute fasziniert
seine fans halten ihm die treue suchen
auf aktionen wie dieser die nähe zum
einstigen kaiser sie kaufen sich einen
teil von diesem menschen einen teil
ihres idols das ist fast schon
fetischismus
im gedenken an ihn ist die nation
gespalten in napoleons schlachten
starben etwa drei millionen menschen er
war kriegstreiber eroberer diktator und
führte in den kolonien die sklaverei
wieder ein
gleichzeitig ist napoleon für viele
franzosen das symbol für größe für
umbruch seine gesetzessammlung prägt den
alltag bis heute lud der chor zivil von
1804 von dem heute noch etwa zwei
drittel gültig sind regelt zum beispiel
die einbürgerung die eigentumsrechte und
auch die zivilehe das makro nun
napoleons grad besucht wird auch als
politisches signal gewertet mit dem er
vor allem konservative stimmen gewinnen
den silos heute jetzt schauen wir was
der sport macht das bist du christoph
viel los gleich rein in die königsklasse
großer jubel bei manchester city das
team von pep guardiola hat erstmalig das
endspiel der champions league erreicht
nach dem hinspiel erfolg besiegelte
mancity zu hause mit 2 0 gegen paris
arena das weiterkommen im nasskalten
manchester wurde ist trainer pep
guardiola schnell wieder warm ums herz
denn mehr noch als beim 2 2 1 erfolg in
paris zeigte sich sein team auch in der
heimat als die bessere zweier
hervorragender mannschaften zum
matchwinner schloss sich der algerische
stürmer riad mache es der seinem treffer
im hinspiel der ist dann zwei weitere
hinzufügte sein trainer konnte
anschließend in seinem schlichten
englisch tauben die richtigen worte
finden
wir haben es ins finale geschafft was
für ein schönes buch mancity und ilkay
gündogan werden so viel steht schon vor
dem zweiten halbfinale fest im endspiel
auf mindestens einen weiteren deutschen
spieler treffen dem früheren
nationaltorwart jens lehmann wurde
seinen posten im aufsichtsrat des
fußball bundesligavereins hertha bsc
entzogen
lehmann hatte gestern eine auf den
tv-experten dennis aogo bezogene
rassistische nachricht verschickt
ex-nationalspieler aogo hatte im tv das
champions-league-halbfinale kommentiert
und eine textnachricht veröffentlicht in
der er von jens lehmann als quoten
schwarzer bezeichnet worden war niemand
teilte später mit sich bei aogo
entschuldigt zu haben den posten im
aufsichtsrat der hertha war er dennoch
los wir von herta vertreten bestimmte
werte und die haben sich in diesem
dieser nachricht nicht wiedergefunden
deswegen denke ich muss das zu diesem
schritt kommen auch die fernsehsender
sport 1 und sky teilten mit lehmann
nicht mehr wie bislang üblich in ihre
sendungen einladen zu wollen
erfolgreicher auftakt für deutschlands
besten tennis spieler alexander zverev
beim masters in madrid gut in form
setzte sich der 24 jährige gegen den
einstigen us open finalisten kei
nishikori aus japan mit 6 3 und 6 2
durch im achtelfinale wartet morgen der
brite der mir evans 2018 war es wäre
turniersieger vielleicht wieder
vielen dank justine otto und was reimt
sich auf otto genau die gewinnzahlen
lauten 4 56 10 15 21 und die superzahl 8
weitere gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de
und dem zdf text auf seite 55 7
so dann haben wir noch das wetter nach
dem sturm kommt der regen alle details
gleich von katja horneffer ich empfehle
ihnen das heute journal 21 uhr 45 die
kollegin bettina schausten hat fragen an
die bundesfamilienministerin von uns war
es das für heute bis morgen wenn sie
mögen aber erstmal in allen ein angenehm
haben
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren nach dem
sturm ist vor dem regen und nach dem
regen ist vor dem turbo sommer heute
zogen ja etliche schauer über uns hinweg
zum teil waren das auch gewitter es gab
glaube gewitter und in den
mittelgebirgen fiel auch noch mal schnee
bei temperaturen von acht bis 14 grad
heute nacht sinken die werte auf sechs
bis minus 1 grad und die wetterlage
beruhigt sich ein bisschen nur an der
küste gibt es noch kräftigere schauer
sonst ist es häufiger auch nur locker
bewölkt bei einem total noch stürmischen
wind aus südwestlichen richtungen
morgen vormittag gibt es an der christa
auch noch einige regenschauer sonst aber
beginnt der donnerstag freundlich das
ändert sich dann aber in den
mittagsstunden wende mich hier im
saarland in rheinland-pfalz und in
baden-württemberg schon die ersten
regenwolken auftauchen und die ziehen
dann bis zum abend weiter und erreichen
sachsen und niederbayern
derweil scheint in norddeutschland dann
häufiger die sonne bei west tritt morgen
liegen die höchsttemperaturen ähnlich
wie heute zwischen 8 und 14 grad und
dann wird es wärmer am samstag wird's
schon einigermaßen bahn aber am sonntag
erwarten uns dann höchsttemperaturen auf
rügen von 18 grad und am oberrhein von
30 grad und es wird nicht nur deutlich
wärmer sondern auch deutlich sonniger am
sonntag ist das dann wirklich ein turbo
sommer der kaum mehr als einen tag
durchhalten aber noch